what is the most dangerous thing you can
imagine an average person might say an
apex predator or a violent killer
meanwhile a researcher working for the
scp foundation might cite one of the
xk-class end-of-the-world scenarios like
the release of the devourer of worlds as
the most dangerous thing they can
imagine but if you were to pose that
question to an astrophysicist ask what
they think is the most dangerous thing
they can imagine then you're likely to
get only one answer a black hole that
area of space that pulls in anything and
everything around it with its immense
gravity whether it's planets or
asteroids or even light itself nothing
can escape the pull of a black hole
around every black hole is an area known
as the event horizon and once you go
past this boundary there is no going
back if you were aboard a spacecraft
that ended up going past the event
horizon of a black hole you're
essentially as doomed as anyone can
possibly be according to certain laws of
quantum mechanics black holes do have
their own temperature and will often
emit what is known as hawking radiation
named after the renowned physicist
stephen hawking given that black holes
absorb everything they will also pull
this radiation back into their own mass
shrinking as they gradually collapse in
on themselves as for what's inside a
black hole hard to say anything can be
pulled into one but nothing can exist
within it or at least that's what the
world's leading scientists will tell you
other theories have been floating around
there on where black holes might lead
perhaps they might be doorways into
other universes and dimensions beyond
our understanding or maybe black holes
are gaps in the fabric of the space-time
continuum and falling through one might
send you hurdling years into the future
or even the past and then there's
scp-123
something that the foundation keeps well
guarded
scp-123 consists of a gray geodesic
sphere meaning it is a shape comprised
of various connected triangles kind of
like the epcot center built from an
unknown material the hollow sphere
housing scp-123 consists of 60 triangles
with empty spaces between that allow
someone to view the center within it is
what looks like a much smaller sphere
only around a single millimeter in
diameter this inner sphere is completely
black all over emitting zero light and
tests by foundation researchers have
revealed that this dark sphere will also
not reflect light either that's because
scp-123
is as you may have guessed a contained
miniature black hole much like the
larger black holes found throughout the
solar system the core of scp-123 has a
strong gravitational force capable of
gently pulling any objects that are
within three meters of the outer
geodesic sphere towards it any object
resting against the surface of the outer
sphere seems to become double its normal
weight as it gets caught up in the
powerful forces within however while the
pull of the black hole is at least
weakened somewhat by this outer layer
inside the casing the strength of the
black hole is dramatically increased you
would be smart to leave your keys wallet
and phone in another room if you were
approaching
scp-123 as any small object that can fit
through the triangular gaps in the outer
shell will be pulled into the black hole
in the center when brought close enough
solid objects will rapidly accelerate as
they are snatched up by the force of the
anomalous sphere only for the object to
vanish entirely from view as it's lost
to the void within according to tests
conducted by foundation research teams
the same occurs if liquid is ever poured
through one of the outer sphere's gaps
and it will be sucked away into the
black hole like water down a drain
further observations made by the
foundation's researchers confirmed that
all light near
scp-123 curves towards the black sphere
in the center interestingly black holes
cannot normally be seen or observed
directly with the naked eye due to them
being able to pull in light so instead
astronomers and astrophysicists will
monitor changes in the area surrounding
a suspected black hole for any notable
changes the miniature black hole of
scp-123 shares these light bending
properties but also appears to be at
least partially observable while
contained within the outer geodesic
shell while the foundation is still
unsure as to what the outer sphere is
made of it seems to act as some sort of
cage keeping the black hole stable and
secure otherwise the cage itself along
with the entire planet outside it would
presumably be sucked into the center in
fact research staff have even been able
to roughly calculate the mass of the
interior black sphere and have
determined that the cage surrounding it
somehow reduces the gravitational
effects of the black hole scp foundation
experts state that the black hole within
scp-123 currently has a mass of
approximately 10 to the 29th power
kilograms within the outer shell but the
cage's dampening effects may mean that
the inner sphere's actual mass could be
even higher under ordinary circumstances
a black hole with a 10 to the 29th power
kilograms of mass would have a schwarz
child radius of about 200 meters any
professional astrophysicists in our
audience will already be well aware that
a schwarz child radius is the size of
the black hole's event horizon if you
remember earlier we mentioned that an
event horizon is the area that surrounds
a black hole and going past this
boundary means that you now have a
one-way ticket into the black hole
whether you like it or not the fact that
scp-123 doesn't have such a large event
horizon and that only objects placed
within the outer sphere are pulled in
shows that the only thing stopping the
black hole absorbing everything around
it including all of us is the cage it's
currently held in nothing can escape the
pull of a black hole no solid matter no
liquids not even light however in the
case of scp-123
it seems that there is at least one
state of matter that this black hole is
unable to absorb gases even though
gaseous matter is affected by the
gravitational force of scp-123
for some unknown reason gas cannot
breach the gaps in the outer shell
surrounding the black hole the scp
foundation is still studying why only
solids and liquids may pass through the
cage while gas cannot but it's almost
certainly for the best after all if
scp-123 could absorb gas and pull other
elements into its mass there would be
little to stop it from sucking up all
the oxygen surrounding it somehow either
by an intentional design or by the
natural properties of the material it's
crafted from the cage around the inner
sphere seems to protect the outside
world from the miniature black hole it
prevents the entire planet's air as well
as the rest of the planet itself from
being pulled in and crushed while also
keeping the black hole at a far more
manageable size the two components of
scp-123 seem to behave in a symbiotic
manner acting together as one when
someone moves the outer cage the black
hole will follow and stay in a fixed
position hovering inside the center of
the geodesic casing just what exactly
makes both of scp-123's parts behave in
such a way has left even the
foundation's top researchers baffled
while a miniaturized black hole could
potentially cause devastating damage for
now at least
scp-123 doesn't pose much of a threat as
long as it remains contained by the scp
foundation within the confines of the
geodesic cage the black hole itself is
nearly harmless only pulling in small
objects as a result the foundation has
been able to securely keep scp-123
inside one of their facilities the
contain miniature black hole is fastened
to a sturdy table with the use of straps
and chains however personnel are
forbidden from affixing any hooks to the
gaps in the outer casing otherwise these
run the risk of being dragged into the
black hole's gravitational pull
potentially along with whatever the
hooks were attached to the foundation's
researchers monitor the black hole 24
hours a day 7 days a week 52 weeks a
year devices for measuring the
gravitational force of scp-123 are
placed within the same room the black
hole is kept but at a safe distance of
100 meters away staff are also
instructed to never place objects within
the outer shell of scp-123
and are prohibited from inserting any
objects through the gaps in the geodesic
sphere unless an experiment is taking
place at all times
scp-123 is to be treated with the utmost
care as if it was a fragile object and
for all the foundation knows of the
unidentified outer sphere it could well
be if the cage containing the black hole
was ever breached anything within 200
meters would be pulled into the center
of scp-123
as all forms of nearby matter were
absorbed the black hole would begin to
increase in size pulling anything and
everything into itself as it continued
to grow before long the entirety of
planet earth would be collapsing in on
itself all poured towards one single
point until the planet fractured perhaps
the scp-123 black hole would release and
then absorb enough hawking radiation to
seal itself but by that point the world
as we know it would be gone a true xk
class end of the world scenario with
pretty much nothing the foundation can
do to stop it once it's already started
even scp-2000 would be worthless once it
was sucked inside the miniature black
hole so when we say that
scp-123 needs to be handled with extreme
care we truly mean it the fate of the
world depends on it meaning no one
member of the foundation should ever
shake the sphere around or exert any
kind of force onto it during any
transfers
scp-123 is not to be transported over
large bodies of water in case it begins
to pull the liquid into its center
researchers working near and studying
the miniature black hole even have to
adhere to a strict dress code to avoid
their clothes getting absorbed into the
spatial anomaly any member of foundation
staff interacting with scp-123
is instructed that they must wear
tight-fitting clothing so no straps or
laces no chains or other dangling
jewelry and long hair has to be tied
back sounds a lot like a school uniform
dress code right it might not be all
that fashionable but it's a small price
to pay to avoid getting painfully pulled
through the small triangular gaps in the
outer shell into the black hole within
the only question left is what do you do
with a tiny perpetually stable black
hole when left alone
scp-123 doesn't really seem to have much
of a purpose but it's certainly good at
getting rid of things so well that you'd
never ever see them again the contain
miniature black hole's gravitational
force has led to some higher ranking
individuals in the scp foundation
discussing
scp-123's potentially usefulness as a
disposal unit after all nothing you'd
throw into it would ever come back
however the head researcher studying
this phenomena is concerned about the
structural integrity of the geodesic
cage that the black hole is kept in
anyone looking to dispose of something
using scp-123 must first get this
doctor's approval to do so or request a
formal hearing with a foundation higher
up otherwise any interactions with the
miniature black hole are restricted with
experiments still ongoing to determine
how strong that outer cage is and just
how long it's going to hold for because
if it ever breaks trust us you'll know
now go check out
scp-3001 red reality and
scp-2317 the devourer of worlds a door
to another world for more truly cosmic
scps